Pokemon almost 20 20 20 years old let's
do it we're all old we're all gonna die
but in the meantime let's enjoy Pokemon
let's celebrate it in fact I calling up
there's a bunch of pokémon stuff in
GameSpot we're sort of celebrating the
anniversary that I'm actually Zelda as
well within a week of each other there
six days apart
Zelda's the 21st and pokemons the 27th I
think cool so there's a bunch of stuff
in the side I wanted to do a little
something about Pokemon on the lobby
today so since we're gonna be
celebrating Pokemon I thought why don't
we just kind of [ __ ] on Pokemon living I
talked about what the worst Pokemon are
mmm cuz there's some pretty bad poem so
I asked both of you mm-hmm to tell me
what your least favorite Pokemon is
Peter Brown we've got your one up first
I think what is what is the worst
Pokemon do you think of the 7 billion
Pokemon than that exist I am a very
superficial person that judge things
based on their appearance okay and
mushara is the worst in that contest it
looks like a fetus with intestines
leaking out of its forehead oh god it
does the top of its head is I is
actually shut you see the size show with
eyelashes above its rosy cheek for the
people listening on the podcast this is
really not gonna play but don't worry
about that's okay that's pretty bad yeah
guess I continue know that that's pretty
much it it looks awful it's like the
presidential debate everyone gets
through these favorite pokemons so I
it's it's the stupid keyring one oak
left key klefki this is something you
find at the bottom of your purse like
whatever I don't know I Pokemon are
supposed to be organic right they set
them up is like these are creatures in
the world and you fight and you bottle
them and they do whatever what the hell
is this it is not hearings don't don't
appear in the wild neither do bags of
trash or what was that other one that's
really all
you want to see bag of trash I think we
owe the sword that we've trubbish right
there there there's trouble you have
garbodor no garbage is the is the
evolution right yeah it so much it's
like they ran out of animals to work
with or whatever we've got more we've
got clink as well I think let's just go
through them let's see what pops up and
see if I can remember
oh that's Smoochum the kissing I haven't
seen half of these cuz I gave up in
Pokemon because of this yeah yeah the
hundred twenty was pure now it's all
going crazy that's clink-clink is a
bunch of gears so it's multiple gears
it's not a single gear no it's two gears
it's the oak that's a slurpuff which I
believe is episode really made them up
come on yeah Chinpokomon yeah lambda
lambda on yeah okay this is the best
named one of all
this one's called Luvdisc noel UV d is k
love dis Luvdisc yeah i think we might
have is that it is on all of them i
think that's all i saw them say man
don't link it turns out a lot of shitty
phone there's a sword there's a sword
ownage no no let's describe oh let us
know in the comments folks over there's
garbage or garbage oh there's my baby
boy
he's like cement there you go thank you
so much for coming in and sharing on
pokemon with me but we'll be celebrating
pokemon on gamespot calm and next week I
think week after lets out this next week
I think never sure nut stuff so a lot of
cool written features and videos on
GameSpot calm but let us know what
Pokemon
the most in the comments below